20h30 quartier beau canal les voitures
ont du mal à circuler sur la portion de
route qui se trouvent aux abords du
stade
dans une ambiance musicale soutenu les
visiteurs des quartiers avoisinants sont
venus assister au spectacle de se faire
mal les deux équipes qui s'affrontent le
font dans le cadre de championnats
vacances qui a lieu trois fois dans la
semaine des joueurs d'âge très différent
ce quoi sur cette pelouse
c'est bien qu'ils viennent ici s'amuse m
ça ramène de l'animation de découvrir
aussi du talent qui font le bonheur de
l'équipe de m parmi ceux qui profitent
de cette animation
désir sa spécialité les bout quitte
cette ébullition autour de son commerce
lui permet de mieux terminer ses fins de
mois et
café des titres victor jean baptiste
l'initiateur du tournoi prépare déjà un
autre événement dans le quartier autour
de lui d'anciens coéquipiers de club
aujourd'hui membres de son association
ici on veut en faire mais vraiment vous
et moi sérieux on trouve pas d'idée déjà
succombé tôt le rapport êtres humains
c'est quelque chose
il commençait à y a qu'à voir ce qui a
choqué a eu dimanche le sport général
vous permet de côtoyer des individus
comme ça qu individu vous le croirez
jamais le sport c'est le bief la sautée
l'épanouissement le choix sur le terrain
c'est la mi temps
les oranges du hall 14 même de busan les
bleus de la différence espère refaire le
retard pour repartir avec les billets
d'avion promis au vainqueur
malgré l'enjeu l'ambiance reste cordial
car l'essentiel est ailleurs ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu de
le divertissement comme ça nos la gare
entier donc c'est un plaisir de se
retrouver entre amis et de faire un beau
tournoi pour animer le quartier un peu
sans quoi difficile parce que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
non je martèle m'a avisé par leur désir
de prendre la relève
il est ils sont dans une autre monde
donc il appartient à ma génération est
choquée manteau de mettre en place un
choc pour que lorsque le bois en tirant
dans l'urgence qui est vraiment une
continuité convivialité fraternité sont
les devises que victor jean baptiste
tente sans relâche de transmettre aux
nouvelles générations quartier beau
canal petits et grands se côtoieront
durant toutes ses vacances ici
la magie du foot aura à sa manière
encore fait des heureux